I just turned 36 yesterday I guess he's
the former cabs forward announcing his
retirement Richard Jefferson back on the
program Richard where are you right now
ah we're about it on the bus and has the
parade right now do you have to turn in
your Cavaliers ID uh no not yet Thank
I'm Oh Tom are you not are you still a
cavalier yeah right now helmets longer
uh well I don't know my teammates are
trying to are trying to uh talk me out
of it yeah so what we'll see well wait
wait wait we'll see so this isn't set in
stone you're retiring no it's not set in
stone my mom my teammates Ron and those
guys you try to talk me out of it
they're saying I'm crazy if I retire so
we'll see it it still is still up for
debate well if LeBron is asking Richard
can you turn him down unless you got
something else there another job no no
not one out I don't have I don't have
too many options but you know I'm just
enjoying this right now and then we'll
reevaluate some things when I'm done I'd
say the truth damn it was way too
stressful I'm too old a distressed like
I'm already 36 like we made this we want
10 straight lost 2-1 to Los 211 yeah it
was just it was just too much for me are
you being serious no I'm saying I'm
being here damn I I was it was the most
stressful oh it was enjoyable but it was
like when you're down 20 in the in the
finals you're like oh damn we gotta get
this right then you win one you feel
good you lose when you're like 31 no
teams ever come back for free why then
you start getting even more stressed out
about it and then it's just like then it
was just like after you win game you win
Game five you can't celebrate we win the
game six you can't celebrate and then
finally game seven was like the most
intense game i think i've ever been a
part of my life and it was writing all
of a sudden you're the champions and
you're like what just happened what was
it like after game for you down 3-1
what's the locker room like
well we were a little pissed off we were
pissed off that you know we shot like we
let it get away with we felt like we let
it get away we had an eight-point lead
in that game and we made some mistakes
you know we made some errors that
allowed them to get back into the game
and ultimately win so we were frustrated
cuz we really felt like it should have
been 22 but after that after we kind of
calm down the next morning we were like
look if we win Game five this series
going to go to seven if we win five
it'll go to seven and anything can
happen in seven so that was kind of like
our mindset our mindset was just win one
game and Golden State which we were
going to have to do anyway and then we
knew our home crowd we knew how good we
are at home we knew that like we really
had a good chance to win that and that
anything could happen in a game seven
what you did how much motivation did you
get from the Warriors and how they acted
and how they hell they talk draymond
Green klay Thompson you know there was
there is a there was a there was a
little bit of motivation but at the end
of the day they've earned the right to
talk that way now you have to back it up
to continue talking like that but you
know they earn the right to talk like
that they're the defending champion you
know they had the best record they had a
two-time MVP they had you know um you
know they had the best regular season
record of all time so it was like you
know they they definitely approached it
with some arrogant but you know you earn
that you know but you know so it was
tough to get mad you know dream on
saying like hey if I playing game 5
there's no doubt we win this game we're
going to win it on their core first you
know we're going to do it two years in a
row in their court yeah that's
motivation but when you're down 3-1 you
know it's the NBA Finals like you know
how much more more motivation do you
need he's Richard Jefferson the Cavs
forward not retired yet world champion
Joe name is Stan Patrick so what did you
learn about LeBron James to help out how
happy what did I learn about LeBron the
last I do arithmetic isn't these well
I've known this for a while but just
being there and seeing it every day you
know he's a baddest man on the planet
you know um you know that's you know
that's just who he is like he's a guy
that just says hey you know follow me
you know he's a guy that just says you
know he'll take the challenge of
bringing a whole city a whole
organization everybody's hopes and
dreams you know he does that
you know he does that and that's not
something that I've really seen from any
other player in my life did you go to
dellavedova's for beer pong last night
uh yeah we did delhi and it was my
little flip cup over there um yeah we
had we had a good time has Luke Walton
as Luke Walton reached out to you about
joining his staff with the Lakers no he
are Luke uh yeah I told Luke that I'm
retiring I need a job and he said um he
said I can't he said if you retire
you're an idiot and I can't have you saw
my staff that was that was that was
pretty much that was the end of that
conversation so now I will not be
joining the laker staff I think they're
doing a great job filling it out right
now yeah Luke's gonna join us later on
this morning but his his wife I guess
they're close to delivering so we're not
sure if we're having Luke on I know I
know my birthday was yesterday I was
really hoping as a kid we're gonna be
born on my birthday so I could talk even
more trash to me but I yeah I don't
think that's going to happen so they
missed that deadline hey I wish you well
with that decision to be able to come
back and play and if not whatever
whatever the future holds for you
Richard we appreciate your time dad dad
dad you're amazing that you're amazing
don't ever change you're awesome I've
been watching and listening to you man
my whole life's pants off yeah I just
want to tell you I'm a big fan awful
well thank you Richard is there a way
when you get the microphone that you
could drop passion bucket your passion
bucket is full if you could do that
today it'd be kind of nice to give me
back something since I gave you all
those great memories on Sports Center
all those years haha I don't know what
that means are you setting the upper top
no no it's all positive like Kobe is
said it before Kevin Love said it before
it's my passion my passion bucket is
full yes like after you why our passion
bucket was full going into set a game
seven and there was no way we were going
to lose Cleveland is going to embrace
passion bucket it's not a negative trust
me ok ok I want make sure you're not
setting me up no I would not do that I
would delhi dova but not you uh you ever
delhi ok that's good yes I'd yeah I'd
have fun with the Prague I know you got
to go alright Passion bucket
thanks Richard there you go the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience